colonial pipeline attack tip of the
infrastructure rise
risk iceberg dhs cyber chief fox
business story after a hacking group
forced colonial pipeline the nation's
largest system for refined oil products
to shut down suddenly government
officials are warning cyber attacks
against u.s businesses and
infrastructure
will become more frequent acting cyber
security infrastructure security agency
director
brandon wells made that clear during q a
while testifying before lawmakers on the
senate homeland
security committee if there is ransom
ransomware focused on colonial there is
likely to be ransomware
focus on other critical infrastructure
as well isn't that true
as senator rob portman republican ohio
the ranking member of the committee and
wells responded that is true the attack
on the colonial pipeline said to be
the work of russian ransomware group
darkside
is training supply and panic and drivers
who have lined up at gas stations
up and down the east coast with north
carolina virginia declaring
a state of emergency and then obviously
this has caused the gas stations and
southeast to run out of gas as pat
people panic
buying fuel gas stations in south
southern eastern united states face
significant
outages wednesday this makes it in this
stretches into the sixth day as of 7 a.m
eastern standard time 24.8 percent of
all gas stations in north carolina 15.4
of all gas stations in georgia 15 in
virginia are without gasoline let me say
that one more time
a quarter of all gas stations in
carolina that's the third largest
economy in america
according to uh the city is you know
it's it's
it's a big number right then when you're
looking at that according to gas buddy
as an ab track field demand
the supply chain appears to be much
worse in metropolitan cities
gas body reported outages impacting 71
percent of stations in metro charlotte
nearly 60 percent in atlanta 72 in
raleigh 73
in pensacola anyways i can give you a
bunch of stats what are your thoughts on
what's going on with this
well you want to start with this no go
ahead okay well
there's two different stories here
there's the actual cyber attack
on colonial pipeline um i think it's
important to point out that uh
sort of a big miami uh
journalist type guy made a major
announcement he's like people in south
florida don't worry about this
we do not get our gas from colonial
pipeline we actually get shipments
from the ports so this is not affecting
south florida so
for local people they were like all
right cool but
there's i guess two stories going on
here number one um
the cyber warfare i mean you could
probably speak about
warfare way better than i but warfare is
now turning cyber
and this is a major concern i think it
was ted koppel
um that that i spoke with a few years
ago
at a big nalba event and it was kind of
2016 when trump was talking about the
wall and all that and it was hoopla
hoopla goes look
the biggest issue we should have we
should all be thinking about is
uh cyber warfare and obviously after
kovid
you know whatever you would call uh
pandemic warfare
but also the electrical grid like
imagine if they can take out the
electrical grid that'd be absurd
so but the good news is this has been
rectified
everything is kind of getting back to
normal and then back to that's sort of a
macro level then from a
micro perspective kai if you want to
pull up the picture that i just sent you
this reminds me it's to use the metaphor
from the
from kovid people freaking out buying
toilet paper i got to get toilet paper
i'm a hoarding toilet paper
it's ridiculous i need the toilet paper
and it's like why did we all need all
that toilet paper during coven
i didn't i had covet i didn't wasn't
going to the bathroom more than usual
so here's an example that i saw online
this couple is filling up
a suv full of gas
this is classic but the kid's probably
sitting in the back yeah they're
smelling all of that you know the guy's
300 pounds you should probably just take
a walk for a second
but rather than driving the suv that's
just that's just me i got personal i'm
sorry buddy i take that back
the wives cavs look like bo jackson's
that's just me again legit but
legit but this is what's going on this
is people
overreact they rush to judgment listen
all night last night
if you ride up and down the highway
you'll see lines you would have seen
lines all night last night
they don't really have a problem here
but people panic
just like the toilet paper and i don't i
i really never figured out what the
toilet paper had to do with the covet
stuff
like toilet paper i don't know
nobody got diarrhea from covet no that
was not a symptom
no it was not a symptom i still can't
smell six months later but
i've been able to bathrooms is pretty
normal not a bad problem yeah
yeah so uh you know the toilet paper uh
was an issue
just like the gas people panic they
panic
and it's usually out of ignorance um the
problem we have
you know at all the things that you
mentioned you know the grid
issues the electro electrical grid uh
the water
uh basins you know are they uh
are they problematic could they be yeah
they could be
but the bottom line is cyber
is probably one of the deadliest threats
we face today
as a national security risk because you
have
russia you have china you have el
salvador
north korea north korea these are
all you know they all have their
elements out there
that are trying to attack the us
without doing it publicly and how do you
do that you get into the banking systems
you get into systems like this um
they could do a lot of damage a lot of
damage
and that's what we have to worry about
and and here's what's interesting
can you pull up that tweet that i sent
you this is this is pretty insane to be
thinking about how ridiculous this is
getting
here's u.s consumer product safety
commission
do not fill plastic bags with gasoline
yeah plastic bags
plastic bags with gasoline what do you
mean plant do you even have to tweet
about the fact that the only reason
they're tweeting that is why
because someone's dude maybe they think
it's a water bag or something hey let me
go fill up plastic how do you even fill
up plastic
this is this one this is what irrational
actors are thinking about
when they hear that there's a gas
shortage and they don't own one of the
big red buckets because homeboy over
there just bought
ten thousand when put them in his truck
and now your only option is i gotta go
fill up a garbage bag versus gasoline
and you're freaking out like you said
they're uninformed and they're just
acting
so so here's what we want this is the
largest u.s pipeline
number one largest u.s fuel pipeline
okay
dark dark side hackers took 100 gigabyte
of data they stole
okay they have a a double extortion
scheme
there's a ransom they want here in
return if you go look up who dark side
hackers are
they operate on the dark web it's not
political they flat out tell you we are
not political we don't lean on the left
or the right or anywhere
we simply just want money on their
website they tell you which
companies they've attacked which
companies they've hacked
what they've gotten on their website
clearly and they say they have a very
value-based principle
they don't go after funeral homes they
don't go after an insurance company they
don't go after
companies that take care of a elderly
they're they're such
oh what nice the principles what they're
principal
thieves
and uh biden came out and said look this
has nothing to do with
uh russia uh meaning the government it
has something to do with
the the people that are hacking are from
russia but
we don't know if they're linked to
russia or not obviously gas price is one
of the highest
in seven years but if you really think
about it here's what you got to be
thinking about
so go and think about what kova did to
us for 12 months
how much should kova cost us i was
talking to noam chomsky
and he said such an interesting thing he
said look what
osama bin laden did to us he said osama
bin laden during bush and obama
he got the us government his goal was to
make us government go bankrupt chasing
this guy
u.s spent 3.6 trillion dollars just to
catch this guy
he says what human being in the world
has
ever been worth 3.6 trillion dollars
the most expensive human being ever in
the world
was osama bin laden think about that the
most expensive human being in the world
was osama bin laden that's how much you
have spent
to go capture the skills right 3.6
trillion dollars so now
you come back and look at something like
this how much should covet cost u.s
how much would cost five trillion plus
sold so far
in excess of five in excess of 5.6 okay
five to six trillion dollars forget
about the printing money all this stuff
five to six trillion dollars right and
now things are coming back that
uh you know fauci was part of a funded
project i don't know if you saw that or
not that they
helped out with china years ago and now
they're kind of wanting to remove their
names but on the bottom of it this lady
who did this
uh a report on the bottom she says that
this research was funded by i think it's
nih which fauci's name is on that now
fatch is coming back and saying we had
nothing to do with this
and they're saying how reckless this
could have been because the virus could
have come out et cetera et cetera
what does this have to do with covert
and fauci here's what it has to do with
it
the the threats you know you know how
they say what is that one line you know
if wars were fought in you know
uh the next world war three will be
fought with what sticks and bones you
know sticks and uh with words
no no no no sticks and stones meaning
it's going to be the end of the world
they're going to
i don't think that's going to be the
case if you actually think about what
the next wars are going to be
the toughest things about the next war
is you don't know who's doing it
there is no fingerprints today it's
tough to find the fingerprints today how
do you go back and see who's behind this
thing here how do you not know these
were
operate you know people who are working
on the inside with the russian
government that are doing this how do
you not know that this is funded you
don't know that stuff the paper trail
to find a lot of stuff is tough today
you don't know but why because it's done
online
the the hackers they can find ways to
eliminate their ips so you don't know
where it's coming from and
these guys are becoming so good at what
they're doing today so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye